DAVID THORBURN:
I'm David Thorburn.
I'm a Professor of Literature
and Comparative Media.
What else?
I've taught the film
experience for, I guess,
38 or 39 years at MIT.
And I've taught a lot of
literature subjects as well.
The story of what made me into a
film scholar or a media scholar
is at least interesting to
me and still surprises me.
I've told it a few times.
But it was actually a somewhat
transforming experience
in my life.
I had been teaching at Yale
for seven or eight years.
And I was offered a chance to do
a visitation at the University
of California in Santa Barbara.
And for the first
time in my life,
I was asked to
teach students who
weren't the product of very
elaborate private school
educations or very powerful
public school educations.
They were smart kids, but
they were less well-read
in some ways.
So I was trying to illustrate--
it was a literature
course, Introduction
to Literature,
or Comedy, or
something like that.
And I was trying to
introduce the students
to the idea of
conventions, what it
means when you begin a
story, "once upon a time,"
and every story begins that way.
Or what it means
when you say, "they
lived happily ever after,"
to take the simplest example
of what a convention is.
I was trying to illustrate
how, in fact, we internalize
these things, and we understand
the narratives of our own time,
in our blood, without
even thinking about it.
And I was trying to
illustrate this principle.
So what I needed to
illustrate the principle
were shared texts.
So I began by asking them--
this was in the 1970s,
in the early 1970s.
And I asked the
students there-- these
are bright California
public school
students-- how many of you have
ever seen a John Wayne movie?
Maybe 10% of the
students-- in 1970.
It's not 2016 now.
Maybe 15% of the students
raise their hand.
Then I said, well, how many of
you have read Huckleberry Finn?
Maybe 30%.
I tried other novels,
classic novels.
I tried Shakespeare plays.
Finally, I said, how many of
you have seen All in the Family?
For those in the audience
too young to know this,
All in the Family was a
television program-- a classic
and transforming
one-- that appeared
in 1971 on American
television and involved
a working-class hero who had
never-- such characters had
never appeared on
television before.
It was a very important program.
And, of course, 100% of
the class had seen it.
And I began to take my examples
from television programs.
I talked about the conventions
of situation comedy
as a way of explaining.
And I began to think about this.
And this wore on me-- it wore
in on me as the term went on.
And what I realized was that
the literature of our own day,
the story forms that
belong to my students
and to the generation
of kids I was teaching,
were visual, not literary-- or
at least, many of them were.
And the ones that were shared
100%, shared by everyone,
was certainly televisual.
So I became interested
in television
as a narrative medium.
And then I came to
realize, as I began
to think more seriously
about the role of television
in American life-- remember, by
1970, American television was
deeply embedded
in American life.
It was the dominant form of
entertainment and narrative
in American life.
And in fact, this
initial understanding,
out of which my whole
interest in media developed,
has shaped-- I realize
now, just in talking
about this-- my way of
teaching the course,
the film experience--
and it's one
of the things I think that makes
the film experience unique.
Because I began thinking
about television.
I was not a film scholar.
I was not a media scholar.
I was a literary scholar.
In fact, ironically,
I was a specialist
in the high modern
period, a period of Joyce
and Virginia Woolf
and Picasso, right?
And I knew about
what we might think
of as-- I was an expert
in art-- in forms of art--
that could be thought
to be elitist,
or at least non-accessible
to the ordinary people.
And here I was confronting texts
that everyone could understand
and everyone shared.
We get to think about
them more deeply
and think more deeply about my
own literary education, which
was narrow in some sense.
As everyone in my
generation was so educated,
we were cut off from the
historical implications
of the texts we studied.
So I began to fill that
in as well, as I began
to learn more about television.
And what I realized,
thinking about television,
was I couldn't understand
television without the movies.
So I then set on a sort of
personal course of education,
and I read very deeply in movie
history and movie scholarship.
And I amplified my own
knowledge of movies
tremendously by constant
viewing of movies,
mostly because I was trying
to understand television,
ironically.
And then I began to
develop a recognition
of what a remarkable cultural
phenomenon the movies were.
I began to generate great
respect for the great movie
scholars.
It was a great era, the
late '60s and early '70s,
for movie scholarship,
because it
had become mature by that time.
And the people writing movie
criticism in the United States,
certainly in the 1970s, were
very interesting critics.
Critics and scholars,
the equivalent
of the literary
scholarship that I
was used to, that I aspired
to write myself, and so forth.
So it was very exciting,
intellectually,
for me to have this experience.
When I got back to Yale,
after my year's visitation,
I introduced a course called
Literature and Popular
Culture in which I explore
these ideas in greater depth
and with greater intensity.
I read some bestsellers.
I ended the course by
looking at The Honeymooners.
And I remember I was
teaching the course in a room
at Yale College called
Linsly-Chittenden
Hall, in which the great
Shakespeare lecture course had
been taught for generations.
And my course, Literature
in Popular Culture
was very popular
with the students.
I had a couple of
hundred students.
And I was lecturing
from the same podium
that legendary figures had
lectured on Shakespeare about.
And one of these
legendary professors,
the man who had
actually hired me
at Yale, Maynard Mack, a
great literary scholar,
poked his head in while I was
teaching The Honeymooners.
And I had actually dragooned
the medial people at Yale
to give me a reel-to-reel
tape recorder so I could
tape the stuff off the air.
Mack saw this and later
called me into his office
and expressed great
disappointment over the fact
that I was polluting
this environment.
So we then had a
serious conversation.
And I said to him, what
did he actually think
Shakespeare's environment was?
And that was when it struck
me how narrow my education had
been.
Because he really had not--
even though he was a great man--
he knew the history.
But he somehow had managed to
disconnect the literary power
of Shakespeare from
the fact that it
was done on this
incredibly popular stage,
and it was so sensational,
and it was so much more
like television or
the movies than it
was like some process of
sitting in a library in wood
paneled splendor reading
words in silence-- that's
not what Shakespeare was.
And that began to lead
me into recognitions
of the importance of
popular culture, the fact
that most high culture was
a form of popular culture.
I became much less
apologetic than most teachers
of popular culture are.
And so when I came to MIT in
the mid-- I came to MIT in 1976.
And I was already in
the throes of this.
But it was, I think, fortunate
for me and fortunate for MIT,
in one sense, because MIT's
literature program was much
more open than Yale's had been.
And they were interested in my
work on television and media.
That was one reason they
wanted me to come here.
And it was much less hidebound
about literary and historical
study here.
So it gave me a chance to--
and I introduced a course
in television.
And that was one of
the very first courses
in an the American Academy that
studied television programs
for their content.
Now, that's common.
It's thought to be-- of course,
everybody takes it for granted.
But at that time, it
was a very rare thing.
And what I also did was take
a course that I inherited from
my wonderful colleague--
still teaching here in his
80's-- Alvin Kibel, a course
called the film experience
which was of a course, that was
not intended for all students
but a small one I transformed
it into a general introduction
to film and I've taught it
almost every year since.